we won't be doing that today tomorrow
tomorrow works
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
i can save today
but you can save the world
steve
[Applause]
you know you need to do
[Music]
it's uh that's just a trash can it's
just a trash can yeah yeah welcome back
everyone it's charlie this is gonna be
my new wonder woman 1984 trailer video
we also have a special justice league
2021 announcement that's really cool and
some more wonder woman 1984 footage that
they're going to be dropping really soon
that i'll explain so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for wonder woman 1984 on the
video so just going down the list
starting with number five warner
brothers just made a couple big
announcements about its movies for the
next year it shifted everything again by
a couple weeks some movies more than
that wonder woman 1984 is now going to
come out october 2nd this year instead
of august that's because mr batman dark
knight himself christopher nolan's movie
tenant got delayed by a couple weeks so
all the other movies that warner
brothers releasing after that just got
moved down the bench by a couple more
weeks themselves now we can joke that
wonder woman 1984 is the new mutants of
dc movies it's had at least three
different release dates so far and even
when they made the announcement
yesterday too they tweeted out this
picture that had all these thanksgiving
messages on them like they had planned
on releasing wonder woman 1984
thanksgiving this year but then changed
their minds to october as chaotic as
that sounds don't worry we're still
gonna get to see the movie it's just
being bumped by a couple weeks into
october so it's not that bad it could
have been way way worse the special new
wonder woman 1984 footage that they're
going to be releasing is actually going
to be coming in july around july 17th
when they re-release inception in
theaters another big christopher nolan
movie they're trying to get people to go
back to movie theaters so they're
re-releasing a ton of really really big
movies it'll be brand new wonder woman
1984 footage from the movie so whatever
it is i will totally do a video for
breaking down all the easter eggs they
didn't say whether or not they're gonna
post that online so you probably wind up
having to go to the theater to see it dc
is also doing a big special virtual
comic con event later this summer
separate from the actual comic con where
they'll do panels from the upcoming
suicide squad movie with james gunn and
a bunch of wonder woman 1984 stuff a
bunch of the batman stuff probably so
that'll all be separate maybe some other
trailers from that too
but number four the really cool
announcement about justice league next
year that'll get you even more hyped up
if you're already excited about the
snyder cut is that because of the way
all these movie releases are changing
justice league is probably going to wind
up being warner brothers biggest spring
early summer movie blockbuster and it's
not even being released in theaters i've
already done a couple videos about how
that version of justice league is going
to be radically different than the
theatrical cut so i'll link them at the
end of this it'll be a totally different
movie and speaking of wonder woman gal
gadot she and the other justice league
actors will be coming back to record new
dialogue for zack snyder's alternate
footage the new version of the movie is
going to be over four hours long and
they're saying around 75 percent of that
is probably going to be totally
different story and footage than the
theatrical cut so there is a lot of
extra dialogue that needs to be recorded
for say like the dark side scenes who
they're putting back in the movie
thankfully darkseid is coming back in
the other scenes just to stitch
everything together in a way that makes
sense but right now the report is
they're going to be breaking the movie
up into six different parts and airing
it on hbo max like a mini series next
summer so it's basically going to be
warner brothers biggest summer
blockbuster event no official release
date yet but it'll probably be sometime
between late april to early june and it
would just run for six weeks six
different episodes if you don't have hbo
max right now i'm sure they're going to
run some promo and they'll be dropping
trailers for that before the end of the
year and early next year too just to get
people even more hyped up like please
subscribe to hbo max to get this amazing
thing we're releasing but number three
none of that stuff is going to connect
to what's happening in wonder woman
1984. the big hope for the justice
league snyder cut is that if it's as
successful as it seems like it's going
to be warner brothers will just be open
to continuing that part of the dc
universe with other types of stories and
projects like that on hbo max in the
future if they announce that they're
doing the same thing for suicide squad
and changing that with an alternate cut
of the film i'll do a video for that too
but thus far they've only said that
they're doing it for justice league
right now wonder woman 1984 and wonder
woman 3 are only loosely connected to
the previous justice league dc eu movies
in the sense that it's still gal gadot
playing the character and in present day
she'll still know aquaman batman the
flash cyborg superman and apparently
shazam now now that shazam met the
justice league before the ending of that
movie but the strategy that they're
using for their new dc movies going
forward is they're letting the directors
do more self-contained movies if they
want so some of the dc movies going
forward will still be connected to
justice league and some will not two
great examples of that on opposite ends
of the spectrum are shazam 2 in the
batman movie with robert pattinson so if
you didn't see the news a while ago
henry cavill is signing a contract to
come back as superman man of steel in
the dc universe but crossing over into
other upcoming dc movies he's not
signing a contract for man of steel too
one of the movies he would cross over
into would be shazam 2. i'll do a new
superman movie video sometime soon too
because there was also a report about
what's going on with that next superman
movie and when warner brothers is
playing on actually doing that on the
opposite end of the spectrum in terms of
continuity the batman movie with robert
pattinson is not going to be connected
to justice league it's going to be its
own self-contained thing it takes place
in the past and robert pattinson isn't
supposed to be a prequel version of ben
affleck's batman he's just supposed to
be a younger version of a batman number
two the new wonder woman 1984 stuff is
mostly about wonder woman and cheetah's
character arc the way that they're
setting up cheetah for possible future
returns in other dc movies or even
wonder woman 3. so this is basically
what cheetah looks like in the movie
there have been a couple promos that
have been released of what she actually
looks like at various points during the
film but the whole idea is that she
slowly becomes cheetah over the course
of the film so she evolves into the
comic book cheetah form and it actually
does look pretty good on screen maxwell
lord is the closest thing to a main
villain the movie has but even he isn't
really a villain in the way that aries
god of war was the main villain of the
first wonder woman movie if you're going
into the movie kind of expecting the end
to be similar to the first wonder woman
movie you will be extremely surprised
the movie could not be more different
rewatch the trailer a couple times
notice what's missing from all the
scenes wonder woman does not have her
sword with her in present day and even
when she puts on the special war armor
with the gold wings from the comics she
doesn't have the sword and she doesn't
have her shield at any point during the
trailer just the lasso of truth patty
jenkins and gal gadot said that she's
not using those the shield or the sword
in the movie because she isn't going to
be running around chopping body parts
off of anyone no gods no regular people
no meta humans not even cheetah or
maxwell lord and it's all part of the
idea that the movie isn't supposed to be
about wonder woman defeating villains or
fighting villains it's all about how
wonder woman saves everyone or at least
tries to save everyone number one the
whole thing with the cheetah story arc
is that she starts out as this awkward
historian and archaeologist working with
wonder woman at the museum they become
friends and because barbara minerva
thinks of herself as trash she wants
nothing more than to have what she
perceives to be wonder woman's power and
grace she wants to be wonder woman
because of what maxwell lord does with a
special black stone that becomes
literally possible for her so cheetah
effectively gains her cheetah abilities
and becomes powerful like wonder woman
over the course of the movie but in the
movie because this is all about the
excess and greed of the 80s it's about
the metaphors of greed turning people
into monsters but because it's a comic
book movie and you have a special
magical black rock it also literally
turns people into monsters so that
explains how cheetah begins to look like
comic book cheetah over the course of
the film and in terms of her coming back
in future dc movies that would either be
wonder woman 3 or another dc movie but
they haven't said specifically which one
it's just the idea that she could always
come back if kristen wiig wants to come
back like i said though the big special
new footage that they're releasing for
wonder woman 1984 that'll be sometime
around july 17th when they re-release
inception in theaters they'll be
dropping a bunch of footage for upcoming
warner brothers movies wonder woman 1984
is just one of those
let me know in the comments though if
they bring cheetah back in a future dc
movie where do you want her to show up
again there's a bunch of stuff coming up
in the next couple of weeks so i'll try
to do as many videos for everything as
possible as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when i post them but
leave all your requests in the comments
below everyone click here for that
justice league snyder cut teaser trailer
and click here for that brand new
spider-man miles morales trailer thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you